hey guys it's Inca I am still here at
tasty Japan today I'm gonna be doing
something that I think is super
interesting Japan I feel like is really
famous for a lot of different sandwiches
something that's become really popular
is this sandwich that I've actually seen
in convenience stores and supermarket
through whipped cream and then like
really fluffy milk bread can't really go
wrong with it I also know that Japan is
really well known for having really
expensive food people are putting more
care into growing them developing them
the whole process is something that
involves a lot of attention and detail I
have a stock where I would find some of
these expensive fruits and then make
them into these popular fruit sandwiches
that we've been seeing everywhere foods
in Japan are also just amazing I was at
the store and there was just so many
things to choose from chill whole grapes
Muscat grapes strawberries oranges
melons I ended up buying a little more
than I should have ten of these are the
fruits that I bought how much was this
this is like almost like a hundred
seventy one hundred eighty dollars worth
of food so first off these are what I
thought were oranges but I guess there
are more like tangerines meat cup up
minute mica mica mica they were a
thousand three hundred and fifty yen I
think that's a route around like twelve
dollars for seven oranges which is not
bad we're starting off at it and an okay
price these are whoa whoa whoa there you
go look at that strawberries look at how
red and big and just like fresh they
look this is called Ichigo in Japanese
Hunley confirming with everybody behind
camera and this was 2160 yen which is
around twenty dollars I would say it
cost
okay I know Costco is not a good
comparison but at Costco you can get
like a whole box of strawberries for
like five dollars third one
already this is Muscat grapes should I
take the plastic off I'm like I almost
don't want to touch the grapes this is
really expensive look at these boxes
like this looks like huge iPhone box I'm
like so excited but I also have to be
slow and that combination just doesn't
work for me there we go
holy crap this looks like grapes from
Getty Images you know like stock image
grapes cuz they're so perfect oh my god
I just want to eat one can I eat one
right now nobody would care right no I
shouldn't I'm gonna wait these are also
in season right now apparently so I bet
they're gonna be amazing okay
grapes very exciting wait is this just
called Muscat grapes and Japanese Muscat
Moscato Muscat them Moscato musk the
more I say it the worse it sounds so
he's our 5400 yen are there even fifty
grapes here we're looking at two dollars
per great putting that back in its
little cushion and then this one oh look
at this even has a lot of gold sticker
so shiny
[Music]
Wow
perfect melon I've ever seen this melon
is our most expensive out of all the
fruits it was eight thousand six hundred
and forty yen which is around eighty
bucks
that's a really really expensive melon
but look at the pattern on this melon if
there was like America's Next Top Model
for fruit this is like the winner right
here
then you take it out or should I I'm
gonna drop it
my hands are also shaking Wow it even
has a little Bowl can also just talk
about how they like trimmed this
perfectly to eighty dollars I hope it
means it's really really sweet so now
let me reset the table and get ready to
make some super gourmet sandwiches
we're just gonna crimp all the fruits
cut this up into bite-sized pieces and
then we're ready to go into this
sandwich segment let's get started heal
all the leaves off hey I did it
that wasn't too bad that's one okay
that's the only ruin this strawberry
that means I can eat it right
oh my god holy crap that's so sweet oh
my goodness there's like a tartness
there it's like when you eat a lemon
tart and it's like tart and sweet at the
same time what out oh yeah me did it I
said I did it and then it broke oh we're
just going to try to clean off these
little fibrous bits this is commercial
level tangerine it's like a little
cocoon of juice oh that's sweet whoa
this is how you get your kid's vitamin C
they're gonna either not stop
look at this cross-section
so good oh really I'm eating melon candy
I keep on saying candy candy doesn't
even do it justice likes a candy cuz
it's so sweet but it's not the
artificial sweetness it's like it like
the sugar of nature think of like a
really good Honey Crisp apple in the
fall pick it off the tree and you eat it
that first bite that sweetness but times
100 that's what we're talking here now
for grapes peel its skin off my mom used
to do this for me as a kid great you
know somebody loves you when they peel
fruit free all right here we have our
beautiful tray of pachinko chain fruits
very very catching catching so now all
we got to do is get the whipping cream
get the bread ready and we're ready to
finally make the sandwiches well over
here we have everything we need
I believe we have the beautiful fruit we
have the whipped cream beautiful whipped
cream that Gabi made painfully in the
back kitchen we put in sugar vanilla
essence and teeny a little bit of rum
just to make it a little more gourmet
we're using really expensive fruits here
so of course I had to buy good bread so
I went to the bakery this morning to buy
some
choke up on fluffy milk bread these just
came out of the oven so I'm super
excited about them they're so fluffy so
we're just going to lightly cover this
up with some whipped cream alright now
that we have cream on both sides we are
going to put in our food so I plan on
cutting it diagonally so I'm going to
put the fruits in like so tangerine
we're gonna put a grape
okay here's we go the grape oh okay and
then we're gonna put emmalin-- damn okay
gonna go heavy on the melon cuz you know
why cuz it's the most expensive this is
an expensive sandwich so it's now we're
gonna cover it oh my god this is
please don't just fall on it okay all
right here we go oh boy okay first
sandwich because you kind of want it to
stabilize so we're gonna do is actually
saran wrap this saran wrap it's not my
friend
tightly I need another tray hold on
because you kind of really want this to
press down together so I'm gonna
actually cover this with another tray to
help squish it down chill it in the
fridge for half an hour to an hour and
then we'll see what it looks like but
okay it has been half an hour where's my
knife it is now time for the final
reveal okay honestly it looks the same
but haha okay you want to make sure
you're actually cutting it the right way
we're gonna trim off the sides please
don't mess up please don't mess up oh my
god I'm squishing the bread
last one almost there Oh Oh God
no we we we we we we we we yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay I should not have
done that know what happened oh god oh
my god go back in there okay this is why
you have to put it in the fridge for a
longer time
I'm gonna cut it off one by one actually
why are you doing a close-up of this
don't show this all right moment of
truth to Jung okay now it looks good
right expensive fruit sandwich how do I
get all the food mmm the bread is so
good the melon when I bit into it the
juice just like it's kind of heavenly
[Music]
Wow
I'm gonna get a couple more people to
try this I have a very special guest
here who's going to try this sandwich
for me he's somebody who has tasted a
lot of expensive fruit in Japan so I am
curious to hear what he thinks are you
ready to do this I'm sorry this is Simon
from Simon and Martina hello
Martina code Omega the Simon's here I'm
super excited yes I'm really excited
it's my first meal of the day
oh really yeah actually it looks not bad
here we go
that's delicious yeah nobody would say
no to the same haha great one was so
good a great one is so good I love to
break one I'd say great number one okay
strawberry
okay then melon then orange if you just
make a whole sandwich with that grape
you could sell that I would back that
restaurant I'd be your first customer
that grape sandwich was legit
alright I'm doing it I will try anything
you want to make no I was a little
doubtful before I came here but alright
what do you think he did yeah thank you
[Music]
good music me the see a third you see
you know what do you buy this yeah I
think like you can the rum is actually
very strong no you know I'm not in a bad
way that he just thinks robbed me but
it's us you definitely taste it and it's
good you know who really likes putting
alcohol in their food create that's
where I was like making fancy alright
put some booze in the heresy
[Music]
you